we would now like to consider a system
of particles and let's draw them as one
two three and let's refer to this one as
the jafe particle of mass M J and these
particles system of particles is in a
gravitational field and I would like to
consider the torque about some point s
for this system of particles and in
particular I'd like to know how do I
treat the gravitational force that's
acting on all of these individual
particles
well the way we'll analyze this is
recall that the definition of torque
about some point now we have J n
particles labeled by index J it's a
vector from the place where calculating
the torque to where the J the particle
is located so we draw that vector our s
J and we cross that with the force
that's acting on the J the particle
which in this case is the gravitational
force and J G and this is the torque
about s and it's this complicated sum
but the son will simplify in the
following way let's just write out a
couple terms to see what it actually
looks like so we have our s 1 cross M 1
G Plus rs2 across m 2g and we just keep
on going for the n terms now the
quantity m1 is a scalar units of
kilograms in SI units but the cross
product is between this vector and that
vector so I can actually rewrite this as
m1 RS 1 cross g plus m2 RS to cross G
etc and you see that the Jeep term is
the same for every single object so I
can write this sum J goes from 1 to n as
MJ r SJ and pull the G out of the sum
because every term has the same gene in
the cross product now let's focus on the
meaning of this sum where we're waiting
position by now
recall that if you have the center of
mass of an object and we want to find
out where is the location of the center
of mass with respect to point s then we
can calculate this vector R SCM by our
definition that the location of the
center of mass with respect to s is
given by the sum j goes from 1 to n of
MJ r SJ and we divide that by the total
mass and j will denote this term I am
total for the total mass so what we see
here is the total mass times RS cm is
equal to exactly the sum that we have in
that expression m j RS j that's
precisely that term and so we can
conclude that the torque about the
center of mass is M total our s cm
across G now remember again M total is a
scalar the cross product is between
these two vectors and so finally we
write this as our s cm cross and total G
and this is how we apply the
gravitational force to a system of
particles now what does that mean well
let's just denote our system like this
and let's say here's the center of mass
and here's the point s so what we need
to do is we need to draw the vector R as
cm and apply all the gravitational force
at the center of mass and then our
torque about s is the vector RS to where
the forces acting cross M total G so in
conclusion when you have a rigid body or
a system of particles and you want to
calculate the torque due to a uniform
gravitational field then we place all we
act the total gravitational force is
acting at the center of mass and that
gives us the torque about s
the individual torques of the system of
the gravitational force about s all the
force is placed at the center of mass